new york le 22 septembre
jeffrey raimon est un peintre d'un genre
un peu particulier
depuis des années il réalise les
portraits des grands patrons de wall
street
je viens de terminer un portrait de
rands greenberg l'ancien dirigeant de la
compagnie d'assurance à igé situe level
exposé à wall street au pied de leur
immeuble et je vais demander aux
employés ce qu'ils en pensent
au coeur de wall street la cible du jour
de jeffrey c'est donc en greenberg
le boss d'alger qui a mis en péril la
première société d'assurance au monde
ça vous temps d'écrire un petit
commentaire mais non non non
c'est pour le soutenir
non moi je me contente de faire le
portrait après vous mettez ce que vous
voulez vous voulez un peu trop madame
hésitations des passants peur peut-être
des employés mais la colère est bien là
l'amérique ne peut plus voir ces grands
patrons même en peinture
[Musique]
on parle ici des économies des gens pour
leur retraite tous les gens qui
voulaient avoir une fin de vie
tranquille
découvre aujourd'hui que tout s'est
envolé à cause de la stupidité de ses
dirigeants
je sais juste que c'est lui qui nous a
entraînés dans des investissements à
risque et voilà où on en est aujourd'hui
ces gens là se prennent pour des dieux
faire des bons jusqu'à ce qu'on les
mette à genoux
chacun d'entre eux devra être jugée
réponde de ses actes
ce mec est un tocard il est parti avec
des millions de dollars vous voulez
vraiment que j'écrive ça ce mec est un
tocard ils le sont tous vos patrons est
en tout cas ce mec est un tocard
signez là ce sera mieux
[Musique]
sept ans après les attentats du world
trade center à quelques mètres de ground
zero un nouveau septembre noir pour new
york l'amérique et bientôt le monde
j'inspire panique pas d'explosion mais
une implosion
va de morts mais des millions de
victimes
pas de ruines mais des millions de
ruiner
15 septembre 2008 lundi noir à wall
street
la seule chose qui tourne encore chez
lehman brothers ce sont les ports
1 à un employé et traders s'en vont avec
leurs cartons
je vais devoir chercher un autre boulot
et pièces qui arrivent pour les autres
tous les autres ils vont arriver dans
quelques minutes tu fais alors à
beaucoup je pense que ça va être
[Musique]
à new york à londres à shanghai sur tous
les continents le monde de la finance
regarde s'effondrer l'une des plus
vieilles banque d'affaires américaine
lehman brothers est à court d'oxygène et
lui manque 17 milliards de dollars pour
continuer à respirer
pour moi la la chute de lehman c'est le
moment où on sort de la période de la
crise gérable pour entrer dans une
période où la crise se développe selon
sa propre dynamique selon sa propre
logique et où les hommes politiques non
plus de grande prise sur les événements
[Musique]
la chute de lehman est le point de
départ de la plus grande crise
financière mondiale
le premier jour de crack année zéro
wall street s'effondre l' indice dow
jones connaît sa plus grosse chute
depuis le 11 septembre 2001
sous le choc l'amérique se regardent
enfin dans son miroir le pays vit à
crédit largement au dessus de ses moyens
le gouvernement tente de rassurer les
marchés par la voix du secrétaire au
trésor henry paulson
[Musique]
face à la très grosse crise
malheureusement s'aperçoit que l'europe
est une fiction
le monde découvre l'ampleur d'une crise
sans précédent et sa complexité
difficile d'en comprendre les causes et
dans imaginé les conséquences
pour tenter de comprendre les raisons de
la crise retour au péché originel
tout est parti du marché immobilier
américain
devenu une immense machine incontrôlable
et incontrôlée une immense machine à
fabriquer des emprunts et donc des
dollars
stockton en californie le symbole de
cette amérique à crédit ici une maison
sur 25 appartient désormais aux banques
3000 familles se retrouvent à la rue
tous les mois
et la nouveauté c'est que la crise gagne
toutes les classes sociales veronica
ochoa est institutrice mère de quatre
enfants
acheter une maison c'est le rêve
américain monde veut pouvoir s'en
acheter une quand tu es propriétaire
cela veut dire que tu as réussi
la difficulté ensuite c de la peau lié
pendant quatre ans veronica paiera ses
mensualités régulièrement jusqu'à un
arrêt maladie qui lui sera fatal
j'ai appelé la banque et je leur ai dit
je suis malade et j'ai perdu mon emploi
la solution qui m'ont proposé était de
vendre la maison
mais je dois plus d'argent à la banque
que ne vaut la maison
j'ai arrêté de les rembourser en juin
juillet et août est et ma maison a été
saisie c'est devenu un cauchemar ce
n'est plus un rêve il n'y a plus de
solution
en pleine tourmente financière
la maison de veronica est tout
simplement invendable
elle a été prévenue elle va bientôt tout
perdre
quand ils saisiront la maison ils
viendront ils regarderont tout ce qu'il
y a pour tout estimé et ils garderont
tout pour couvrir les mois de retard que
j'ai accumulée
je vais donc sortir de chez moi avec
seulement ce que je porte
et vous avez peur de devenir son
domicile
la maison de veronica risque de finir
ici dans l'une des ventes aux enchères
qui fleurissent en californie les
banques en manque de liquidités brad par
centaines les biens saisis ja oui on est
dans une crise financière mais en même
temps c'est une énorme opportunité pour
acheter une maison
une chance unique ne va pas durer plus
d'un an de
ce jour là venus du monde entier des
centaines d'acheteurs potentiels ont
fait le déplacement avec tous en tête la
même idée faire la bonne affaire
le malheur des uns fait le bonheur des
autres
c'est ce qu'a compris pilar à mme alonso
brésilienne elle vient d'acheter sa
sixième maison de la journée
c'est triste c'est vraiment très triste
parce que ces gens qui travaillent qui
ont payé leur maison ou de très mauvais
financement avec des contrats qui n'ont
souvent pas compris
et leurs maisons disparaissent c'est la
classe moyenne américaine qui travaille
et maintenant vous êtes en train d'en
profiter oui j'en profite mais j'ai
encore une conscience je reconnais que
moralement ce n'est pas bien
[Musique]
chandhok une moitié du pays un max
encouragée par le gouvernement fait du
shopping avec de l'argent virtuel et de
multiples cartes de crédit l'autre
moitié est d'engager dans des guerres
dangereuse et morale elle à l'étranger
franchement la moralité
le problème qui a provoqué cette
situation vient des états unis
premièrement c'est une faute de la
banque centrale américaine d'avoir
baissé les taux d'intérêt beaucoup trop
bas 1% et puis les gens se sont endettés
ils ont acheté des maisons
atout qui s'ajoute à cela le fait que le
business du marché hypothécaire
américain est orienté d'une manière
incroyablement spéculative spéculative
[Musique]
f
si on n'a pas le droit de retirer du
marché des morceaux de papier qui ne
valent plus rien ça devient toxique pour
tout le monde
c'est comme une usine chimique qui
explosent elles relâchent un nuage
toxique dans l'atmosphère eh bien c'est
ce qui s'est passé ce poison s'est
répandue dans le monde entier
londres le 18 septembre
deux jours après la chute de lehman
brothers la crise débarque en europe
c'est la première journée noire pour les
bourses européennes
pour échapper à la faillite les deux
plus grosses banques britanniques
fusionnent
gordon brown est le premier dirigeant
européen à monter au front oui peut-être
[Musique]
le même jour à la city de londres
au pied des building du quartier des
affaires les traders ont la gueule de
bois
et au vu des enjeux à la moindre
question sur la crise le silence est
d'or non non merci
non merci
merci on est en train de boire un verre
peut-être que quelqu'un voudra le faire
là bas
[Musique]
quand vous êtes salarié d'une de ces
grosses banques
voulait représenter tout le temps
vous en faites partie
c'est une culture d'entreprise comporte
toute la journée dans la banque mais
même en dehors c'est pour ça que les
gens ne veulent pas parler
c'est l'histoire qui s'écrit là
c'est excitant
je garde tous les journaux que je lis en
ce moment
d'ici cinq ans les étudiants d'une école
de finances apprendront dans leur livre
ce qui se passe en ce moment c'est
extraordinaire que ça a écrit une
histoire tous les jours
pour comprendre cette histoire qui
s'écrit au jour le jour nous frappons
aux portes des gratte-ciel de la finance
mais un seul établissement de la city
nous accepte avec notre caméra la saxo
bank
steen jacobsen 44 ans est le patron d
investissement
bonjour
vous êtes prêts ce matin là il va tenir
devant cette raideur sa première réunion
de crise un briefing sans langue de bois
pour comprendre ce qui se passe je vais
utiliser la métaphore de l'iceberg si
j'envoie ce qui est au dessus de l'eau
je ne se rendent pas compte que
l'iceberg est bien plus grande
c'est une crise d'insolvabilité nom de
liquidités
personne ne veut prendre les engagements
des autres
personnes neutres est au delà d'une
semaine il n'y a plus de confiance quel
que soit le nom que vous avez personne
ne vous prête plus rien au delà d'une
semaine c'est la panique chez amérique
et compagnie ils n'obtiennent pas les
fonds dont ils ont besoin une telle
panique arrivent tous les 80 ans
fort généreusement dans 80 ans je serai
mort
vous savez ce que je rappelle toujours
les gars qu'est ce qui est écrit sur les
billets américains en dieu nous croyons
riz et bien c'est la seule contrepartie
que vous aurez avec les américains
maintenant ok
personne ne réalise vraiment l'ampleur
de cette crise que l'opinion publique et
les gens de la finance doivent
comprendre c'est qu'il s'agit d'un
bouleversement total on rentre dans
quelque chose ou rien ne sera plus
jamais comme avant
la saxo bank c'est un peu la tour de
babel
aujourd'hui en pleine tourmente le seul
job des traders et de rassurer les
investisseurs
et le fond dans toutes les langues
steen jacobsen prend la température sur
les différents marchés ici celui de
moscou comment vous les sentez les
russes en ce moment ils sont positifs au
sujet du marché
n'ont la plupart pensent avec un certain
plaisir que l'économie américaine
devrait se retrouver au tapis
[Rires]
et comme ce sont un peu les restes de
l'économie communiste
les russes voudrait voir un nouveau
monde où l'on ne paye plus le pétrole
finit en or
ni en dollars
la dure loi des marchés une réalité
assumer sans état d'âme par le patron d
investissement
je suis un spéculateur je suis beau
mais si on veut argumenté là dessus il
faut revenir aux bases un spéculateur
c'est quelqu'un qui spéculent sur les
mouvements de prix donc tout le monde
spécule
dire que la spéculation et derrière tout
cela c'est faux
tout le monde est dans le jeu pour les
mêmes raisons
la tour de lehman et juste en face j'ai
beaucoup d'amis là bas
évidemment c'est dur ils sont touchés et
malheureusement il y en a plein qui ont
perdu leur boulot
mais cela ne change rien au fait qu'il y
avait trop de monde dans les
banques c'était un secteur est beaucoup
trop important par rapport à la valeur
qu'ils rapportaient
le sort des traders de lehman brothers
est ici un gros sujet d'inquiétude nous
sommes à l'université paris 6 masters
probabilités et finance le master des
futurs traders
le jour de la rentrée leurs certitudes
sont sérieusement mise à mal
à la baguette un prof reconnu
mondialement pour ses compétences nicole
el karoui
chaque année elles forment 90 élèves
l'élite des mathématiques financières la
promo 2008 a du souci à se faire la
faillite de lehman brothers faisait
extrêmement lourd en fait on ne vous
cache pas que l'année qui vient est sans
doute l'année d'après risque d'être
quand même d année assez difficile
difficile ça veut dire que la recherche
de stages à plus difficile parce que le
stage est traditionnellement très
étroitement liée à l' embauche et puis
que les embauches aussi seront plus
difficiles
la plupart des étudiants de nicole el
karoui son polytechnicien on les
surnomme les quand pour ingénieurs
quantitatifs
c'est le premier cours de l'année le
thème s'impose de lui même
entendu parler
ici les subprimes ne sont plus un gros
mot synonyme de faillite ce sont des
modèles au tableau noir les titres
toxiques se traduisent en équation
mathématique complexe c'est pas les
modèles qui n'ont pas marché 1 c'est le
business autour c'est le fait qu'ils ont
fait des milliards sur des activités
enfin je veux dire je vais on va pas se
dédouaner d'une forme de responsabilité
mais on va pas dire là c'est pas la
crise des modèles nous on dit pas que
les produits dérivés c'est sans risque
consciencieusement les élèves prennent
des notes des chiffres les équations
mais le coeur n'y est plus vraiment la
crise est passée par là
l'existence palpitante les salaires de
rêve les gros bonus à londres ou à new
york tout cela part en fumée à la pause
cigarette personne ne sait vraiment ce
qui se passe en france c'est vrai qu'on
est assez inquiet quand même parce que
on acquiert un bon bagage ici technique
et un sa master qui est reconnue mais
d'un autre côté on sait que ça va être
difficile pour tout le monde c'est un
marché qui aura du mal à se remettre
debout il y aura des nouvelles activités
du coup c'est pas la fin des marchés
c'est pas la fin des produits techniques
mais ce qu'il faut c'est que les
produits techniques sont manipulés par
des gens qui les comprennent est ce que
vous vous dites j'aurais dû naître dix
ans plus tôt sincèrement ouais ouais
régulation même politique sociale c'est
des gros mots
ça c'est pas des questions qui
m'intéresse beaucoup en fait mais c'est
vrai que j'entendais un débat hier on
vous parlait beaucoup d'éthique de
morale dans cette histoire de crise en
disant que c'était des mots qui
revenaient pas souvent très cas beaucoup
de salariés qui perdent leur emploi à
cause de tout ça voici un truc pour
l'instant ça me mais peut-être parce
qu'on n'a pas commencé à travailler
encore donc on n'est pas trop concerné
par ces questions
new york le cauchemar des étudiants de
nicole el karoui et déjà réalité qui
parmi vous a perdu son boulot
moi moi et elle aussi
et un autre partenaire qui n'est pas là
il s'appelle robert
et tout ça à cause de la crise
financière
moi j'étais trader chez lehman et je
travaillais sur les titres toxiques
vincent lui s'occuper du suivi des
marchés
jean elle était bancaire
moi j'étais bancaire spécialisé dans les
titres immobiliers sommes tous
spécialistes de ce secteur et à cause de
la débâcle du marché on a tous perdu nos
emplois
je crois que le rêve américain est
toujours bien vivant mais ce qui a
disparu c'est une certaine forme de
légèreté la réalité nous a rattrapés
maintenant il est impossible de vivre au
dessus de ses moyens nomi je pense que
c'est une bonne chose
vincent scotto gagnait 50 mille dollars
par mois il doit vivre aujourd'hui avec
une allocation chômage de 900 dollars
par mois les subprimes je lui ont fait
perdre son job mais qu'importe le rêve
américain il y croit encore
[Musique]
salut les gars qui se passe
phaneuf
après le discours du président hier ça
bouge pas mal
suivi le discours oui c'était incroyable
c'est quand même dingue de se retrouver
dans cette situation
avec ses amis chômeurs vincent a décidé
de remettre ça et n'a qu'une obsession
se refaire et sur le marché qu'il a mis
à terre
l'immobilier il veut désormais
conseiller et investir pour les perdants
de la crise
a augmenté d'à peu près 2 181 points
aujourd'hui
qu'est ce qui s'est passé les gens y
croient les gens sont optimistes
le marché va réagir je pense oui
cela fait plus de vingt ans que l'on est
dans le business de l'immobilier
on a vécu beaucoup de changements
depuis la tourmente vécue par le marché
financier américain
on a décidé de s'associer
proposé à ceux qui ont tout perdu une
solution pour récupérer de l'argent
suite à la débâcle des titres toxiques
aux états unis et à travers le monde
washington le 19 septembre
changement de ton de l'administration
américaine qui prend la mesure de la
crise le secrétaire au trésor de george
bush henry paulson annonce une thérapie
de choc un plan de 700 milliards de
dollars pour racheter les titres pourris
des banques
[Musique]
le plan d'urgence 700 milliards de
dollars une ardoise historique et un
tournant idéologique pour les états unis
ce jour là les bourses remontent mais
pas pour longtemps
au même moment du côté des dirigeants
européens ont fait mine de se rassurer
le vieux continent sa forme et
s'accroche à l'idée que la crise ne
traversera pas l'atlantique
comment vous voyez la situation à wall
street
c'est une situation très grave que je
suis très loin de minimiser ce que nous
savons après avoir travaillé avec la
bundesbank c'est que les effets sont
dieu merci limité
[Musique]
paris quartier de la défense le 29
septembre
chez tradition france une des
principales salles de marché
et on regarde toutes les belles valeurs
du début de l'année les matériaux de
l'énergie et tous ceux qui s'estimaient
ce que plus
les traders parisiens ont perdu tous
leurs repères
j'arrive à jour après jour il découvre
l'ampleur de la crise
d'accor
en pleine débâcle des marchés la
communication est très encadrée un seul
conseiller est autorisé à nous parler
jérôme sharp ya plus de quinze ans de
métier
surtout qu'est ce que vous leur dites à
vos crayons
on leur dit rester à l'écart l'essai de
la forme entre est à présent c'est quoi
l'ambiance aujourd'hui là c'est la
première fois qu'on emploie dans les
journaux le mot en récession c'est
officiel la crise financière a
maintenant
un impact sur l'économie réelle et
aujourd'hui on sent bien que on sent
bien que d'en souffrir
comprend le mans - toute l'année
prochaine
on a des secteurs par exemple qui sont
extrêmement sinistrés comme le togo
on retrouve des niveaux niveaux qu'on
n'avait pas vu depuis 7-8 ans à peu
prendre par exemple un clip comme
peugeot
si on regarde sur sur longue période je
vais mettre ici depuis l'an 2000
voyez que ici ici on est en décembre
ici c'est aujourd'hui marché s'est
repris que on y revenir dix ans en
arrière
est encore plus frappant
general motors ça c'est un graphique à
la ici on est en 1995
l'importance que les gérants à tâches
habituellement aux méthodes rationnelles
de valorisation des entreprises est un
petit peu mis de côté aujourd'hui au
profit de 2 au profit des nouvelles et
de l'information qui sera en permanence
et c'est pour ça qu'on a des marchés qui
surréagissent un peu et qui sont assez
erratique avec des variations une
volatilité qu'on a qu'on a jamais connu
ce jour là tradition france vite à
l'heure américaine comme tout le reste
de la planète finance ça serait
officielle en fin de compte sur les
niveaux de 18 heures
les marchés sont suspendus aux votes de
washington dans quelques heures le
congrès américain se prononce sur le
plan paulson de 700 milliards de dollars
[Musique]
le plan est bien trop tard c'est un truc
horrible ne serait-ce que des
commerçants tu commences à acheter la
camelote en chine pour la fin de l'année
pour les ventes de noël away et qui paye
ton fonds de roulement pendant deux mois
c'est les banques je crois que y'a
combien le fonds de roulement en ce
moment
on
au québec même effervescence ce jour là
la bourse de francfort hélène franck
nage et la correspondante de la chaîne
de télévision ard
cela fait maintenant 10 jours qu'elle
est sur la brèche
[Musique]
aujourd'hui cela va être passionnant de
savoir comment les états unis vont
réagir après la lourde chute d'hier
carrière indices boursiers américains a
subi la plus importante perte de points
de son histoire
hélène connaît la faune boursière elle
observe depuis dix ans et dans la tente
du plan paulson les traders allemands ne
sont pas plus rassuré que leurs
homologues français
comme jeter un regard vous remarqué des
perles de sueur sur le front des gens et
des regards désespérés par rapport à ce
qu'on a vu pendant les derniers mois
certains de ses traders ont aussi
recommencé à fumer bien qu'ils aient eu
toutes les peines du monde à arrêter
vous pouvez me donner le programme
au caire
qu'est ce qui est vraiment raisonnable
c'est une question qui laisse beaucoup
de place à l'interprétation surtout à la
bourse et à malte un poète français a
déjà dit dans la nature humaine de
penser raisonnablement mais d'agir
déraisonnablement ce que nous pouvons
dire maintenant ici c'est qu'il n'est
pas question de paniquer
pourtant ce jour là la panique ne va pas
tarder à venir
à washington en pleine campagne
présidentielle le plan paulson a du
plomb dans l aile
à la tribune parlementaires républicains
comme démocrates se succèdent pour
défendre les intérêts des contribuables
pas question que le peuple américain
paye pour les voyous de wall street
[Applaudissements]
ne laissons pas le ciel s'abattre sur la
tête de notre classe moyenne je vous
implore d'accepter ce plan au bac matin
les derniers arguments ne changeront
rien un coup de tonnerre s'abat sur les
marchés le plan est enterré le rejet du
plan paulson par le congrès je suis en
famille je suis en train de dîner
j'apprends la nouvelle et je me dis si
le début de la fin c'est le début de la
catastrophe
la crise échappe à tout contrôle
la tante et elle d'une décision du
congrès positifs favorables que le rejet
annonce les pires choses
sur les marchés c'est le grand plongeon
à la bourse de new york l'indicé dow
jones perd 700 points en une seule
séance un abîme un record historique
à wall street les traders sont ko
[Musique]
votre sentiment s'il vous plaît
il regarde mon visage
[Musique]
qu'est ce qui s'est passé en un mot
c'est un film d'horreur le plan n'a pas
été votée c'est pas un vrai plan de
sauvetage l'argent c'est juste pour
redonner confiance aux gens pour pas
qu'il pense que tout va s'effondrer vous
allez voir bientôt les gens vont retirer
leur argent des banques parce qu'ils
vont paniquer
et c'est quoi la prochaine étape
il faut qu'il le vote ce plan si les
gens car confiance et si le marché
continue à chuter on atteindra le seuil
où ils n'auront plus confiance du tout
ils vont planquer tout leur fric sous
leur matelas
à vent de panique sur les marchés une
claque pour l'administration bush
[Musique]
il y aura donc un nouveau vote ce sera
le 3 octobre
reste à trouver une majorité le scrutin
s'est joué à 23 voix près il faudra les
gagner tout se trame derrière ces portes
des tractations menées à huit clos une
journée clé comme on en a rarement vécu
georges friedrich il couvre la politique
pour la chaîne nbc depuis 40 ans je
dirais que c'est assez tendu
le 11 septembre aussi été tendue mais
quand ça commence à toucher au
porte-monnaie aux retraites ça c'est
tendu
pour l'équipe bush l'enjeu c'est de
retourner les élus qui ont voté contre
le plan de sauvetage
chaque vente un élu républicain de la
géorgie fait partie de ceux là en pleine
campagne électorale il a d'abord pensé à
ses électeurs en colère contre wall
street lundi j'ai voulu envoyer un
message sans équivoque à wall street
pour les chocs et les réveiller qu'ils
réalisent qu'ils ont des comptes à
rendre car les citoyens américains
doivent savoir que l'on est avec eux etc
à partir de demain les simples gens qui
payent leurs impôts et leurs factures
vont souffrir
trois jours plus tard machine arrière
toute devant la réaction des marchés
chaque vente se rallie au plan paulson
il votera finalement oui aux 700
milliards de dollars
le monde entier se tournent vers les
états unis pour redémarrer l'économie si
nous réussissons à nous relancer cela
aidera tout le monde car l'économie
mondiale dépend de nous
l'amérique s'imagine en sauveur de la
planète finance en tout cas cette fois
ci le plan paulson est adopté
ce soir d'une manière bipartisane pour
répondre à l'une des crises économiques
les plus importantes que notre pays ait
dû affronter nous avons envoyé un
message clair à toute l'amérique qui a
tous les américains ceci n'est pas une
loi démocrate ou une voix républicaine
c'est notre loi
[Musique]
il ya une crise systémique il faut faire
quelque chose pour arrêter la panique il
faut créer un plan quelque chose de
tangible pour éviter l'effondrement du
système et la dépression économique
je pense donc qu'ils avaient raison de
proposer ce plan de sauvetage étatique à
700 milliards de dollars
mais je pense qu'on aurait pu éviter
d'en arriver là
un plan d'urgence qui n'est qu'un pâle
incendie encéphalogramme plat à wall
street les 700 milliards ne font pas
leurs effets les bourses européennes
s'inquiètent il en faut décidément
beaucoup plus pour rassurer les marchés
à chaque fois qu'il ya une crise tout le
monde se tourne vers washington et se
demandent que vont-ils faire je n'ai
rien contre le principe dans une crise
d'une telle ampleur il faut que le
président chinois les gens du golfe les
européens se prennent en main et arrête
de dire que va faire à washington oui
même arrête de dire à l'amérique ce
qu'elle doit faire oui doivent dire
voilà ce que nous allons faire nous il y
à des milliards de dollars dans l'est
mais si le système financier et
mondialisée ses réserves d'argent ne le
sont parce
qu' on aime bien gardé et toujours une
télé allumée pour entendre ce que disent
les hommes politiques
mais le problème c'est qu'il ya toujours
un décalage du point de vue du timing et
de la raison de leur intervention
car la plupart des problèmes que l'on
voit aujourd'hui étaient connus depuis
longtemps
personne n'était motivée pour agir actes
moi ce que je pense c'est que les états
unis n'agissent que lorsqu'on leur force
la main comme par exemple avec le 11
septembre
garder là on a une pile de journaux qui
remonte à un mois c'est le wall street
journal on a décidé de ne pas le lire
les points de vue et les éditoriaux
change tous les jours ils ont perdu le
sens des choses c'est toute crédibilité
sur times square à manhattan ce type
d'abattage r un fonds d'investissement
le quatrième hedge funds dans le monde 1
milliard 200 millions de dollars
steve d'abba n'a pas subi la crise lui
cela fait un bon moment qu'il a senti le
vent tourner sur les marchés
on s'est plutôt bien débrouillé
parce qu'on n'avait pas trop miser sur
les emprunts les plus risqués nous avons
même réduit nos positions un peu plus
tôt à partir du milieu 2006
vous auriez eu du mal à trouver
quelqu'un qui vous aurait dit que le
marché de l'immobilier n'était pas une
folie un marché complètement surévalué
ces deux dernières années
alors en connaissance de cause sans
céder à l'appât du gain tout le monde
aurait pu la nes
la seule question à savoir si vous avez
la force de résister au mouvement
général
comment nous nous avons réussi à le
faire pas par esprit de contradiction
mais on ne voulait pas suivre le trou
en europe dexia ou fortis des banques du
vieux continent sont rentrés depuis des
mois dans le grand casino américain elle
s'écroule aujourd'hui comme des châteaux
de cartes balayés par la débâcle des
emprunts immobiliers
[Musique]
côté politique on tente de réagir mais
dans le désordre l'irlande fait cavalier
seul pour sauver ses banques et la
première tentation en allemagne c'est de
jouer le chacun pour soi
on vient d'avoir une déclaration du
ministère des finances allemand qui
déclarent de manière particulièrement
clair et net que l'argent des allemands
doit servir aux allemands pour sauver
des banques allemandes et qu'il n'est
pas question d'utiliser de l'argent
allemand pour sauver une autre
institution européenne s'est elle sait
jamais on a affirmé avec une telle
brutalité
un point de vue strictement national
on est sidéré de voir le peu de
considération que les dirigeants
européens ont pour l'oeuvre commune le
peu de considération qu'ils ont pour le
marché unique le peu de considération
pour les règles communes que nous avons
adopté et le peu de considération qu'ils
ont par rapport aux citoyens européens
qui attendaient une attitude plus
responsable de la part des dirigeants
européens
[Musique]
christine lagarde est à berlin la
ministre française des finances vient
pour tenter de recoller les morceaux
il faut faire bonne figure elle va à la
rencontre de peer steinbrück son
homologue allemand entre les deux et
fusion de bons sentiments devant les
caméras
en fait ce qui me réjouit c'est que nous
nous voyons assez souvent en toute
sympathie
récemment nous nous sommes même
rencontré par hasard en toscane nous
n'avions pas rendez vous je crois que
nous allons nous voir dans deux semaines
à bruxelles est de nouveau dans trois
semaines à washington
nous parlons souvent téléphone ce qui
fonde la meilleure collaboration
possible
et lors de leur conférence de presse
commune même objectif affiché la
meilleure entente possible
c'est toujours
extrêmement productif de nous retrouver
nous ne perdons pas de temps nous allons
directement aux questions qui nous
intéresse et dans une atmosphère
extrêmement à la fois productive et est
amical et je voulais te remercier et
remercier toute ton équipe de cet esprit
de coopération
la commission européenne est une entité
responsable au service de l'europe des
or bien évidemment on regarde la crise
des marchés financiers en europe la
crise il y a cinq à six grands pays pour
les excuses doivent se rencontrer très
rapidement et de façon très flexible
deux jours plus tard à l'elysée nicolas
sarkozy le président de l'union
européenne organise un g4 c'est à dire
une réunion entre la france le royaume
uni l'allemagne et l'italie toujours la
même idée parler très fort sur le thème
de l'union sacrée chacun de nos pays a
ses règles sa législation sa culture eh
bien chacun a décidé de faire un pas
l'un vers l'autre
pour présenter un visage cohérent
l'europe existait une volonté
unité de façade
relayé par jean claude trichet le patron
de la banque centrale européenne
les 320 millions d'européens qui sont
nos concitoyens dans la zone euro
aujourd'hui peuvent compter sur nous
pour leur assurer la stabilité des prix
des discours qui ne change rien à la
spirale infernale en europe les victimes
de la crise sont déjà là nous sommes à
nantes les responsables de l'afub
l'association française des usagers des
banques les reçoivent par dizaines
chaque semaine
ce jour là serge maître le président de
l'afub lui-même assure la permanence
problème d'emprunts de crédit relais
inquiétude pour les petites économies
personnelles la crise est dans les têtes
et dans les portefeuilles visé dans la
maçonnerie ils défilent comme ça les uns
après les autres là un patron d'une
petite entreprise à laquelle la banque
ne prêtent plus d'argent hélas si vous
voulez les prem's et que pour payer mon
plus relevé draghi la maison par exemple
imaginons mal récents 55000 euros sans
tricherie il reste dix au total de 6 ans
et qu'elle
est là aujourd'hui l'échéance dès demain
et dimanche ça la date et là j'ai pas
plus tard enfin il peut pratiquer en
pâté maison gtp pas que je travaillais à
une crise il ya une crise
parce que les banquiers derrière et donc
pas d'argent et parce qu'ils iront bien
c'est fini dans maison de vie jauge
imoca travaux 4 1 ça vaut pas 4 ça vaut
4 parce que personne pour acheter c'est
pas vrai c'est par la maison catherine
dallaire
les dossiers s'empilent l'inquiétude des
épargnants augmente sans cesse c'est
d'abord ça l'effet de la crise sur le
monde bancaire la confiance n'est plus
là
des trucs
vient le tour d'un couple de retraités
il a voulu placer 50000 euros dans un
livret à la caisse d'epargne on a
souhaité faire cet emprunt avec un petit
le milieu traditionnel avec puis
elle casse la conseillère de la traiter
des cas nous dit non non je vous propose
un produit au top
ringard du coup il signe le produit au
top un panier d'une douzaine de titres
en actions censé doubler la mise en six
ans
40000 euros x 2 égale 80000 en théorie
on comprend tout de suite que c'était un
produit très sophistiqué qui faisait
qu'on achetait quelque chose qui nous
promettaient de doubler et que ce n'est
pas arrivé à terme est généralement
qu'on va acheter on ne savait pas
comment ça fonctionne et et on ne risque
pas de comprendre car c'est ea mais
éminemment sophistiquées et les propos
le montre en main y avait des titres
adossés à l'économie américaine et selon
des proportions des évolutions fassi en
plus il faut être mathématicien pour
tout comprendre au même moment
californie les titres sophistiqué c'est
la spécialité de scott clair un golden
boy installés dans leur ranch comme si
au sud de los angeles
son obsession aujourd'hui continuer à
gagner de l'argent quand tout le monde
en père
pour sa société de fond de classement
c'est vive la crise
il ya vraiment moyen de se faire
beaucoup d'argent en ce moment
marché bouge à la hausse ou à la baisse
de 2 3 ou même 4 % tous les jours et si
tu arrive à choper le bon wagon il ya
vraiment moyen d'en profiter
scott et son associé david font de la
vente à découvert
le short sellings une pratique tout à
fait légale aux états unis qui
consistent à spéculer sur la baisse du
marché
un jeu risqué mais cette année très
rentable
ah oui tu sais je dirais que cette année
mais profits ont augmenté de 80%
squatter david avait prédit l'explosion
de la bulle immobilière et ses
conséquences sur la bourse aujourd'hui
ils en profitent sans état d'âme
la récession a du bon nettoie le système
seuls les meilleurs s'en sortent
en ce qui nous concerne nous les
investisseurs
c'est le scénario par fin
de l'année
il y aura beaucoup d'argent sur le
marché à la recherche d'investissements
et là nous
jeudi 9 octobre quatrième jour
consécutif de chute libre généralisée
des bourses de la planète le cac40 le
dow jones du nikkeï le dax où le footsie
tous les indices des grandes places
financières du monde font le grand saut
on
va pas l'exemple du titanic parce qu'on
connaît la fin mais j'ai un bateau qui
est menacé de couler vous avez deux
solutions ou tout le monde accepte les
ordres du capitaine et des a écopé
sauver le bateau où les gens se battent
parce qu'il ya pas assez de gilets de
sauvetage à ce moment qu'on le pire est
là quand il ya le feu à la maison on dit
toujours que c'est le moment d'acheter
en bourse mais cette fois ci je le
déconseille ray je ne crois pas que ce
soit le début de la fin plus tôt la fin
d'une première épreuve
c'est à dire que ça peut encore
continuer peut-être même encore quelques
années
la crise financière va peut-être toucher
à sa fin grâce au plan de sauvetage du
gouvernement ça devrait se terminer dans
les six mois mais les effets sur
l'économie réelle vont se prolonger
encore longtemps nous ne savons toujours
pas ce que ça va donner on va peut-être
vers une profonde récession on va voir
se développer vraiment des phénomènes
type crise de 29 c'est à dire des replis
on verra des gens réduire leurs
transactions entre eux on verra les gens
privilégiés les encaisses liquide refusé
d'entrer dans toute relation de crédit
et on aura une rétractation de
l'économie
le 9 octobre à washington
les heurts qui s'annoncent sont
cruciales pour l'économie mondiale les
gouvernements doivent stopper la panique
à tout prix les ministres des finances
du g7 les sept pays les plus
industrialisés se réunissent dans la
capitale américaine
christine lagarde représente la france
la féministe
beaucoup de travail qui vous attend
[Musique]
ce soir elle dîne avec dominique strauss
kahn le patron du fonds monétaire
international rencontre à huis clos pour
préparer le g7 rien ne filtre de leurs
discussions
le lendemain 10 octobre henry paulson
préside la réunion des grands argentiers
du monde de la finance
la réunion du g7 qui s'achève annonce un
changement de cap radical
parmi toutes les mesures annoncées ce
jour là l'une d'elles est historique
chaque état s'engage à entrer dans le
capital d'une banque en faillite si elle
met en danger le système financier
planétaire
une révolution pour l'amérique de george
bush
le pays du capitalisme se déclare prêt à
nationaliser des sociétés privées pour
sauver le système
au pays de l'oncle sam christine lagarde
a entendu des mots comme régulation
coordination retour de l'état des gros
mots avant la crise elle a encore du mal
à réaliser
[Musique]
que les sept pays principes et sept
principaux pays sur le plan économique
se mettre tous d'accord sur les
objectifs les principes et que ab comme
les états unis
déclare haut et fort qu'il va prendre
des participations dans son système
bancaire pour le soutenir c'est un
changement considérable intolérable
[Musique]
c'est un changement d'instruments au
service d'une même cause
puisque il ne répète alors hurle journée
ce n'est pas une nationalisation pour
mettre ces instruments au service de la
collectivité cette machination pour
permettre de les sauver afin de les
rendre ensuite au secteur privé donc
c'est purement le contribuable mis au
service du capital c'est un petit peu
comme comme un bateau
qui aurait des fuites et tout le monde
est obnubilé à l'idée de colmater la
fuite qui est dans la cabine de première
classe sans voir que tout bateau coule
pour des dizaines de milliers
d'américains trop tard le bateau a déjà
coulé dans le naufrage ils ont perdu
leur maison et celles ci sont la
dernière attraction à la mode les
promoteurs immobiliers joue les tours
opérateurs pour visiter les biens saisis
et mis en vente par les banques
nous allons visiter une des treize
maisons qui sont à vendre aujourd'hui
les prix sont entre 250 et 400 25000
dollars les taux d'intérêt sont au plus
bas donc c'est le moment d'acheter
[Musique]
celle ci est typique de ces maisons
saisies par les banques les
propriétaires ont arraché le plan de
travail les placards
il ya beaucoup de colère chez les gens
expulsés
et les propriétaires qui ont perdu leur
maison en veulent aux banques et aux
gouvernements qui s'accusent
mutuellement et se renvoient la balle
les visiteurs sont des particuliers à la
flüela encore de la bonne affaire
[Musique]
everardo sagou d'un employé de 54 ans
est à la recherche d'une maison pour son
fils
c'est pour cela que nous visitons car
les prix ont tellement baissé on
n'aurait pas pu acheter une maison il ya
un an
les mecs du gouvernement explique qu'il
va racheter tous ces noms des enfants
mais aucun de ces portefeuilles n'a été
estimé nous ne savons même pas ce qu'ils
valent
donc les mecs qui disent que c'est 700
milliards de dollars c'est les mêmes
mecs qui n'ont pas su prédire le crash
retour à l'âge ans les passagers sont
invités à faire des offres sur les
propriétés qui les intéressent j'ai fait
une offre sur une maison ils sont
contraints de regarder mon dossier
j'espère semaine bon
everardo vient d'acheter la maison pour
son fils pour la moitié du prix qu'elle
valait il ya deux ans
la cloche celle de la vente en amérique
les maisons subprimes se vendent comme
des petits pains
[Musique]
paris le 12 octobre nouveaux sommets de
crime
[Musique]
cette fois ci nicolas sarkozy réunit les
quinze états membres de la zone euro
trois heures de sommeil pour finir sur
deux engagement
entrer dans le capital des banques en
cas de faillite et faciliter au maximum
la circulation de l'argent entre les
institutions financières là encore c'est
le grand retour de l'état
voilà ce que j'attends c'est que
l'europe parle d'une seule fois bien sûr
pour les sortir mais d'une seule voix
ici pour le monde car la crise est
mondiale
depuis le 15 septembre et la chute de
lehman brothers plus de 2500 milliards
de dollars ont été injectés par les
états du monde entier pour sauver
l'économie mondiale
mais cette cagnotte sans précédent ne
suffit pas à rassurer les marchés tous
les clignotants sont au rouge la
récession n'est plus une menace mais une
réalité traque année zéro une histoire
qui ne fait que commencer
[Musique]